so this is fun when i was uh growing up
we had a lot of really great public
service mascots remember those like
smokey the bear mcgruff the the crime
the crime dog right crime dog they
helped me learn about things like forest
fires and whatever mcgruff
general crime
it was just against all crimes so if
there was a forest fire that was an
arson it was kind of both of their
territories
so i thought it would be fun to come up
with some new mascots and introduce them
to you so we can help kids deal with the
issues of today in a segment we call new
public service mascots
so uh first we have randy the always
wear a condom reindeer get out of here
randy
hey
he's not expecting this energy nice to
meet you randy meet you petey good to
see you i am feeling good cause i got a
good positive message hey
make sure you always wear a condom when
you're getting with the girl
simple that's simple that that's
thank you hey unleaded she's like super
hot then who cares man you only live
once you know what i'm talking about
what happened to your message that is
not the right thing to be telling the
kids
ah you know what yeah kids uh wear a
condom if you want to uh ruin sex and
never have a connection with anybody
whatever
but uh if you wanna go raw dogs like i
know you do
oh
you know
randy i use a condom i use condoms you
use condoms i use condoms okay what
about uh do you ever
not
or do you ever tell a girl like yeah i'm
wearing a condom but you're not like you
just you just get a rubber band and put
it at the base
oh like you have it you're betraying
your message you're randy always wear a
condom
yeah yeah yeah do that or don't if you
want to rock somebody's body because
trust me women go insane for the man
vain you know what i'm talking about
no
i'd also look to like to point out none
of that was on the cue card
none of that that was just in your heart
women go insane for the man vein is that
something one of the writers would have
written that's not me that's the
character everybody
what
this has gone sideways this has gone
sideways
uh let's move on here's an important
message from our next friend it's carla
the don't touch fire cow come on out
carla
hi
hi carla how are you how are you i'm
okay i'm okay i'm just here to tell the
kids stay away from fire
yeah that's great thank you i was a
little worried given you know the
reindeer yeah he's crazy it would
but that's a wonderful message kids you
should stay away from fire that's right
you know even though fire is beautiful
and inviting and
extremely seductive
you can't touch it okay i love that
what that's not normal i don't think
many people are out there a year
very normal
to touch fire when we stare into those
flames pete we're all thinking one thing
you know
dive into the fire
be one with the fire
enter the
okay finally to close things out our
last new mascot is pinchy the don't
upload things to the internet that
you're going to regret later crab
pinching
hi pete i'm just here to tell everyone
you're gonna regret it so don't internet
it
that that's great thank you pinchy
that's a relevant message and it was
said cleanly without any weird twists oh
i had to learn the hard way about the
message i've done some dark things that
have ended up on the internet blew a
couple of real big jobs for me
so just trust me all right pete trust me
i okay why someone once posted a video
of me making love to what i thought was
a doll
turned out to be a dead
body turns out it's a classic prank in
the crustacean community
the old doll dead body switcheroo
that's what you guys are up to down
there i thought it was just a crumbling
disgusting old doll but
ah you know
kenji why are you telling me this so
nothing like this turns up on the
internet oh
yeah
i'm afraid to ask did did he use a
condom
i think it was just a rubber band
and uh i got crabs
that's right crabs can get crabs
crabs on crabs on crabs on farms
i'm a hermaphrodite so that's not that
weird
right crabs are hermaphrodites did you
look that up i i was i meant to look it
up
did you get in here that's finchy
everybody that's me brother